d'abord tu mets un tiers de curation un
tiers de citron bonne chère depuis qu'on
est à la fin d'un tiers d'eau 80 mais
dans un verre avec entretien ou même
d'ici là ça dépanne de la grosseur du
tiers et là ça dépend pas même dans un
heureusement on peut mettre que trois
tirs vas-tu que moi comment j'ai fait
pour mettre cap au tiers de ce verbe
fanni à quoi pensent peut-être à toi
j'ai quelque chose à vous dire panis se
veut la petite et pour quoi faire
boulay bluesy le très organisé alors à
tous ce que vaudra un vieux monsieur qui
épouse une fille est ce n'est pas joli
joli c'est quelque chose qui me déplaît
et ben moi ça me déplaît pas tu
t'imagines que je suis jaloux c'est ça
envoyons maryse pour être jaloux il faut
être amoureux je vous vois une paire de
cornes qui tu vas trouille au plafond si
toi que j'aime c'est que je compte
l'épouser je n'ai pas envie de me marier
tu m'as tué me fanny et tu es fou de
rage parce qu'un autre à l'épouser
ne pleurons pas tu le veux eh bien tu
l'auras temps marie luce
partir aux prêts importants
je n'aimerai jamais contents de la mer
moi non plus il est de toute la famille
n'y a jamais eu de sens commun
c'est unique austin sera généreux
allait rappeler plus tard à la mer
celui-ci rappelle un fait mon gars huit
passes pour la vie